good morning millennia since I'm a lot
of thing anymore I was just singing
before the show Jackie was like okay as
someone who now is sensitive to your
singing oh this is something I've been
developed with AIDS I can honestly I
just I can't believe like our sisters
we've gotten to this point and it's very
upsetting disheartening and really
quickly you know what I think the
problem is the problem is that you can't
sing on the show because I love when you
sing on the show and I thought you were
gonna say that you can't sing I love
when you sing like with your full breath
with my vibrato
we're with your fill breast of the
situation but not when you're humming
under under you're like I was just doing
yes I knew I was doing it
please start recording me I would love
to have some premium videos of me
singing I'm telling you is it as your
biggest fan as your number-one fan do
you trust me I don't know anything
honestly I don't know your brand when
you see me I'm sorry I don't need a
healin I don't need a Superman to in my
lovin cuz baby I ain't Wonder Woman dude
oh I can't wait to see her 2019 and the
life we're seemed KCI escapes in like
two weeks I know so she's the 25th right
and the 26 the 25th I have a gig so I
will be seeing her the 26th and I have
to pull some strings I got to meet her
okay well the 26 is Dana's birthday
party so you're the perfect premium at
the concert what time is her birthday
start we are just gonna have to deal
with that with her oh please I'm not
afraid of girls and I'm not afraid of
her but I'm afraid of her on her
birthday
Thanks I'm sorry that sassy shorter
stupid say I've now reached an age where
it's like if I know you and we're up
similar aging you're still doing that on
your birthday like I don't [ __ ] with you
no but it's not like she's doing it like
everyone else like she like innately and
she'll always be this way even though
her birthday this year her party's gonna
be more of a 27 year old soiree you know
like she was always having these like
ragers and now you know the guest list
is has been whittled down to a hundred
whereas before it was at 400 um but
she's just like so obsessed with her
birthday like the day like and
and also her half birthdays right no you
sure be that waiter in her head she also
counts her quarter birthdays Margot used
to be that way and I'm honestly like I'm
glad she were at it because like I I
think there's nothing more unattractive
than like a girl who's like running
around like a grown [ __ ] woman with a
crown and a sash like yeah that's pretty
it's my [ __ ] birthday like honestly I
I won't go to your party if you're like
that like I am now I'm an adult I'm a
mature woman and I can't deal with those
[ __ ] girls anymore like it's so
annoying yes if it's your birthday the
only thing I'm required to do is be nice
to you for that day and that's all I'm
gonna do and I'll show up and get drunk
yeah cool and if you're gonna be one of
those girls in your birthday's also cash
bar oh sorry
if it's cash bar that's all those the
drinks are premium I'll pay for a
premium drink but I won't pay for a
water damn naca soda you know oh of
course you know I'll pay for like a
margarita that works
I had a cash bar at my birthday last
year but it were all such premium
cocktails like you really got what you
paid for
yeah and I had a tab on such PR the
whole time so it was basically an open
bar for me right and you can shout and
oh well don't do this but if you are out
of her that you could have any one of
someone's name in our family and they
probably have a tab open ya know
honestly it's usually me and like
snitches always taking advantage of my
tab also snitches supposed to be working
today a homegirl just like didn't show
up so when she gets here we're gonna
shame her yeah on television
also here's what's going down today
we're gonna deliver the past five
obviously I have some dear toasters and
I have a major update from a very famous
dear toaster that we we discussed a
couple months ago I will reread it for
any new toasters but it involves a law
firm and a lot of bottles of water and
it was quite interesting and I got an
update from the gal so it's our first
segment of beyond the toast yeah shark
tank updates beyond the tank and we're
gonna do one day a patreon episode of
all updates okay um also today's the
first day of nephews weekend out oh yeah
I will be gifted with a precious gem of
a man so after today I'm headed to
Cincinnati Columbus in Detroit to
conceal about girl time job calm and I'm
leaving my nephew up my son in the hands
of his caretaker you guys have never
spent the night together no we have it
like you've never slept with him no so
it's either gonna be like I said if you
lose your virginity everything I didn't
know I needed anymore or it seemed like
wow this is this is more work than I
sign
no it's definitely jarring how much work
it is and you're gonna be surprised and
I honestly like you're having the most
ideal situation cuz I prepped everything
for you like usually if I leave him with
Ben's mom like she knows like I don't do
anything I don't even have food she has
food at her house like I packed up a
sink stew I organized the Walker I
couldn't giving him a bath before like
we're all taken care of I wrote out a
full itinerary for you I want it to be
as easy as possible cuz I want you to
enjoy it a because I want to be able to
leave him with you and B I really want
you to get one and I had a dream that
you did we're so close well you're gonna
be I think you're gonna be surprised at
how much work it is but you're also
gonna be surprised at the joy you feel
when he's so tired and just like crawls
into bed in your legs and like it's just
the joy you never knew existed no I am
aware I'm so excited I'm prepared for
the work though so I actually think I'm
prepared mentally for how much it's
gonna take like I know I'm gonna like
wake up in the morning like instead of
my alarm like with a pit like oh my god
see I was gonna shoot the crate
but he could exude wild control
especially if you walk him as late as
possible the night before for sure but
sometimes he's an unruly boy buddy
literally woke up this morning fortnight
it's like it's nephew speeches day okay
we have a really great Fast Five from
her today um we have a lot to talk about
which we will get to surviving or Kelly
part of the lineups I finish surviving
our Kelly last night I made Margo watch
it she finished it and jackie has one
more episode left we will get to it in
our in our last story so that we can
segue into a recap first story though
Amazon founder Jeff Bezos oh I'm sorry
are you ready for those five stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast which her mate prematurely
ejaculating
I didn't even ask you that was so rude
you prematurely ejaculated that's a
great captain yeah Jackie elation um
that was really rude I'm so sorry
because like you're not supposed to hit
someone with a fast typer new it's like
what a petty you know what if I wasn't
ready think of the think of the tragedy
thank God you weren't ready though
that's the thing about being a morning
show host the thing is you're always
ready by the way I did an actual morning
show this morning I did some like Louis
radio interviews for for Ohio oh man
that's so cool I didn't know that I know
and one of the gals that I spoke to you
this morning was a toaster
she was like in the group's like it's
just so comfortable like I didn't think
she was gonna you know try and set me up
we were just shooting the [ __ ] me and
Erica that's so nice yeah cool okay
first story Amazon founder Jeff Bezos
and wife Mackenzie announced divorce on
Twitter it's over for Amazon founder
Jeff Bezos said his wife Mackenzie the
billionaire announced Wednesday quote we
want to make people aware of a
development in our lives he shared on
Twitter quote as our family and close
friends know after a long period of a
loving exploration and trials separate
we have decided to divorce and continue
our shared lives as friends with it with
one bank account right they marry the
1993 Amazon was founded in 1994 Wow
homegirl you know doesn't have a prenup
cuz he was a nobody working out of a
garage for shirt no but even if they had
yeah but it's all marital property cuz
it was part of like wow wow that's me
wait so this is another week of eligible
men first Dick Wolf and now Jeff Bezos
totally do you want to know an
interesting factoid that's interesting
well here's the thing about interesting
factoids is that the thing is they're
always interesting what is this you're
the same age is Amazon born in 1994 and
though you feel older or younger than
Amazon younger cuz like Amazon's been
more successful you know yeah the son
has more money therefore you just think
that they're older yeah that's so crazy
so crazy according to Forbes real-time
ranking of the world's richest
billionaires Jeff is worth one hundred
and sixty one hundred and six one
hundred and thirty six point six billion
dollars and I was rounded up to 137
right I was laughing well if you make a
return today that might go down that's
so funny of me Jeff beats us the sole
owner of Amazon did he start by did he
get investors right so I just wonder
like of the 136 bit that's what he's
that's what he's what's not with
Amazon's worth a trillion we know that
now Apple and Amazon so homegirl is
walking out with like 70 mil I mean bill
bill but that's so crazy
Amazon's worth a trillion he's only
worth a hundred and forty billion
do you think though like I or think
the company they were just regular
people when they got married in in 1993
do you think they would still be married
if he didn't become like a Chilean there
he was just like had a job in sales he
would still be married like they would
they wouldn't be getting divorced you
mean um I don't know
Mo Money mo problems right so it's like
sad to think like while he changed the
world at what cost but like I'm sorry
but being married from 1993 to 2007 is a
success I'm sure they have kids together
like people grow apart and are there
like Bezos daughters maybe they're
toasters we got to get in with them
imagine imagine um so I'm this is always
saying you're saying cuz like it's
curious to see who they're gonna I'm
just gonna say who do we see for Jeff
Bezos I think he's like a respectable
guy and he won't date someone
age-inappropriate
yeah hmm you never know yeah you never
know it's like when men like leave like
the Robert Herjavec up and all men like
you are the reason I left Finland know
when men who have like full lives and
families and get really successful like
leave and like start a new families like
that's so sad like Robert Herjavec you
know his poor wife okay but like Robert
Herjavec I think the situation's little
misunderstood I don't I'm just saying
what's one of my misunderstanding like I
they were separated he was like very
depressed that Kim like saved him that's
what that's what they said in People
magazine like Robert doesn't lie
really he lies all the time about his
investments no he does he's only ever
really invested in tipsy elves that's
all he could talk about okay
kim feel's is so successful and before i
really became a shark tank expert i just
like took it you at face value when you
said that Robert doesn't invest in
anything doesn't and he doesn't invest
in enough that was what Mark does but he
because they're both in the tech
industry Security's no stop don't talk
[ __ ] about Robert no I'm really I'm not
here for Robert and he's in every
episode you know they all wrote it out
Robert never [ __ ] rotates out because
he's dedicated to the viewers and he got
the production company to it agree to
move his seat because he said that Lee's
FaceTime cuz he was on the end
now sometimes he sits in [ __ ] mark C
can you believe that I know I think you
guys wanted suck when there was like you
guys want to come up and try our new
game or whatever first person up Robert
he's so [ __ ] Thursday he's never said
no to a snack and he's never saying they
love to apples either a demonstration
when they
game we're like they're in the big
bubbles and they bump each other that
was funny Robert obviously was the first
one up oh and he's also like one of the
most limber sharks
no please Lauri she's always wearing the
dress in heels she can't get in a bubble
like that mr. wonderful ruled Gaiman
know Taemin is very active in as his
mark but Damon's on a thirst monster
they're like Daymond you want to try you
get sup know they're like hey anybody
want to demonstrate Robert literally is
like that kidding gosh I'll do it like
it brings a [ __ ] Apple Daymond is an
unbelievable thirst monster no he's not
yes he is no not at all
he's gonna just tell your least favorite
shark yeah who's your second least
favorite it depends I kind of the fall
of them like out of the good legit ones
think you don't go pro guy isn't no okay
but the ones that they rotate in and out
it's hard let me start from the top and
like Rohan's not a shark it's Giuliana
Barbara Lori Kevin mark Robert Daymond
okay my top favorite is a tie between
mark and Lori Wow because Lori really is
a success and she doesn't like sometimes
mark loses me I could talk about
literally our shark tank tangents to
shark tangents mark loses maybe because
he's obsessed with like this
entrepreneurial vibe and he'll write
someone off if they like don't seem like
they're sleeping on their floor enough
you know and yeah and yeah that really
bothers me like that girl with the
applesauce like no not the applesauce
but she was kept her job at News Corp
because she was supporting her old
family and like they wouldn't let me
know but he he did concede on that one
yes but he is the purveyor of that
stereotype because he because he ketchup
packets you know but they each have
something that they get so hung up I'm
like mr. wonderful is like if it's not
proprietary enough for him right he's
out what stuff someone else I'm not
gonna stop her too much I can't take the
biggest umbrage with mark on that thing
because it just for them to want
everyone to like put their families at
risk like that really bothers me that's
why he's tied for first however mark
like another issue that a lot of them
have is a lot of them want to move like
their the production and the businesses
overseas yes more money and Mark is the
only one who stands over them for
American jobs keeping up American jobs
love and he won't like uh what's the
word he won't back down
what do Travis I like he won't blame
someone for it like he won't Nix
now write them off now like mmm like not
to a deal yeah but like what's the word
I just gave you a good no he won't
penalize someone for it
well penal want okay whoever then I
would say after that it's mr. wonderful
because he's [ __ ] hysterical and I
don't I don't agree with any of his
deals or like his business and I can't
but he doesn't that scene that's unlike
the [ __ ] nobody wants but I just love
him I think he's a great actor I think
he's funny it took me a while to get
there after that I would say Damon okay
but you know what it's like
they bring in sharks I mean they bring
in investors like targeted for Damon
like someone who works in textiles like
you see i glitter has the same career as
Damon and he never buys but they like
they always bring in people that like
perfect for Damon and he's like no I
don't want it he goes to this [ __ ] like
nobody thinks he would want you know
when they have that he's checking
diversify the portfolio then Barbra and
then Robert did I forget anyone I don't
know but I just can't believe Roberts
here last like he's literally like see
right through him and his little tight
pants no he's he's as genuine as he
seems I think whatever agree to disagree
Jeff Bezos has to be on Shark Tank by
the way do you think he's like too
successful I think so yeah and I'm like
what is he gonna do really invest in
something when like his investments are
like mate or he doesn't he's not a
venture capitalist he'd like he merged
he's a he for M&A and you know it's so
funny it's like the companies that he
purchases purchase other companies like
ringed was purchased and then ring was
on Shark Tank where as a judge and shark
right ring had some really big press
yesterday I was literally just gonna say
that did you guys see the ring is a
Shark Tank success story but what it is
it's a video doorbell so if like you're
sitting in the kitchen and the doorbell
rings and you know you're not expecting
someone you just look on your phone and
you see a camera it's also good for
security this I forget where it was
somewhere in America this woman found
three hours of footage from her ring
doorbell of literally just a strange man
licking her doorbell for three hours and
she put the video on Facebook and one of
the local news stations picked it up it
is the most disgusting thing I've ever
seen in my life it's hard
maybe he's like a shark tank superfan
maybe that's so girls but it's honestly
not even gross for her because she
doesn't touch her own normal it was for
her visitors but he wasn't ring oh oh
you're right yeah he wasn't look in the
camera he was ringing the bell he was
licking the Bell yeah but it's like if
you didn't go off if he was licking it
no cuz like it depends what kind of
Dorabella days but and its really
require a big yeah it depends on the
tongue if it's shakable or nice tongue
the palpable ring the biggest star ever
by the way what is your doorbell sound
like um it's very doorbell vibes look
like yeah it's not like a - Loman's a
bomb that's nice
I used to have one that was like an iron
that's horrible literally could wake you
up in the middle at night like you think
it's a murderer that's horrible
okay I've always wanted one that's like
hava nagila hava they make those I
wonder if I want one that's like
doo-doo-doo
dude that's what that's super-rich and
it echoes at the home right it keeps
going until you open the door yeah ooh
that's annoying
yeah or just like the climb no cuz that
will ruin your pain it's just like using
a song as your alarm yeah great way to
ruin a song yeah you know the only song
that withstood that for me is all
throughout high school and middle school
my alarm was good and broken by Miley
Cyrus cuz I said to myself like I hate
waking up let me put my favorite song
maybe it'll help and it had that
potential to ruin it but it didn't and
it actually did help it would make like
this this is how I knew I was waking up
was a dune
are you overloaded candy-coat is your
life's imploding now and then I was like
kissing it
taking a pain worth taking on this
hollow ground we can let go of our mana
non-life is hardest part so my next line
when we keep on stop when we keep on
stopping and keep on rocking to the
rhythm of our heart we can we can break
out of here just oh that's really good
yeah that's good I have several arms and
zach has a few songs on rotation ever
since we've been together and they're at
Drake song so if he wanted me to like
his music like it's not helping and it's
like hey there beautiful
drink concert he's what is that it's
Drake's on well and the L says one that
starts with about a pop champagne it's
like beautiful and when we read the
Drake concert he started playing one of
the songs oh my god turn it off that is
so funny well our condolences to the
businesses yeah there's one basis two
businesses maybe there's one Bezos maybe
one two bays oh you know no it's Jeff
Bezos Oh Jeff and Amy Bezos no no it's
Jeff Bezos you know I'm saying one biz
Oh to his oh no I think it's the
opposite it's one Bezos cuz that's you
know the name his family give me some
goose three geese oh baby say zzzz yeah
I condolences to the baby says okay next
story in you know developing news Kevin
Hart says he's not hosting the Oscars oh
really
despite a high-profile high-profile
apology tour the comedian told GMA in a
tense interview that he's quote done
with the controversy and doesn't think
he should emcee the award ceremony when
asked if he would emcee the high-profile
awards show which has been rumored
possibility in recent days Hartwell
GMA's Michael Strahan no and then it's
too late to prepare quote it's hard to
predict what can happen I don't want
people to think there's a thing about me
and the Academy he added as for the
controversy over past homophobic jokes
and tweets Hart said he's quote done I'm
over it Hart said multiple times when
asked about the situation there's no
more conversation about it I'm over that
I'm over the moment I'm
not giving no more explanation of Who I
am I'm just done if you didn't hear the
apology I don't know what you're looking
for he said I'm a good person I love to
love if you don't see that then it's a
problem with you I I do think it's for
the best that he doesn't host
I wonder how Ellen feels after she like
really you know made the phone call but
I think that it would overshadow like a
the award show is it's not even about
the host they're just supposed to be
like invisibly moving the show along and
like a funny way not for the Oscars
they're very visible for the Oscars yeah
but it would just take away from like
the winners and I mean he should do it
in a couple years when all this is blown
over cuz I do think he would be really
good at it but right now I just don't
think it's the right thing for him to do
and I think he's making the right
decision I agree and I had also heard
that he now he doesn't have enough time
to prepare like the show that he would
want to do and I don't think the Academy
deserves him me too you know who the
hell was gonna do it I had heard that it
was Catherine zeta-jones at Halle Berry
ooh but I also heard that from a
facebook comment so I don't know how and
if Kevin Hart doesn't have enough time
to her house anyone gonna have enough
time well apparent Evon heart is like a
true artiste and he like writes his own
jokes if they decide a celebrity up
there but a team of Hollywood writers
writing for them and the teleprompter
they would just need to learn how to
read yes yes but I wonder if they've
hired the writers yet and I'm just
writing like jokes like Mad Libs like
that are Kelly doesn't know how to read
that was the craziest part of the whole
thing yeah he never learned but then how
does he like write his songs that he
doesn't write them down like someone
must like write them for him I don't
know we'll get to it he was like such a
big camp of people enabling him well he
used to you know he doesn't have any
money but we'll get to it yeah you ready
for the next story yeah any more
thoughts on Kevin Hart I'm ready to put
this story to bed for sure he has a
movie coming out though that's a serious
movie with Bryan Cranston and it looks
so good it looks so good um let's see
what I'm leaving out playing on our new
paper theater I'm worried about the
success of it now from what I'm seeing I
just like hearing people converse people
oh wow look who decided to show up for
work today
she says she's not coming you texted me
like over an hour ago so you were awake
yeah where's your bag okay at least you
didn't wheel it in during my sound yet
well hello can I let me got you a couch
yes yes that's it
we wanted you to come or we got you
don't walk in front of the cameras she
learned her lesson
she's so cute keep you with you today
cute look you travel cry um I hope I
think for the most part like America is
like over this story I think a lot of
the people who are upset or now like
upset with Ellen more that like oh
really yeah there's like people are
really [ __ ] unhappy with Ellen but at
the same time like I read things on
Twitter and it's like that doesn't speak
for the people you know what I mean I
agree people on Twitter are just people
who have a platform and they're not
necessarily representing what everyone
in the world thinks so it's hard to
gauge like what the world thinks cuz
like I saw a lot of tweets but like that
doesn't mean like that's what people
think no it's just the people who have
them like who have something negative to
say about it people who don't feel
negatively and are moving on with their
lives aren't taking to Twitter I think
like it's crazy because like it's our
Kelly can um I know everything that he's
done and and I perform at week-long
Cyril Kevin Hart can come out with a
movie no that's my bar now yeah we'll
get to it if we turn every story into
archive at the at the VMAs sitting next
to Lady gaga
I know but that's not me like she's that
was just sitting understand agreed and
the picture made it seem like she was
talking to him she was talking later
guard but even if she was talking to him
the Grammys invited him like VMAs yeah
well you're gonna not talk to your
fellow chair me totally next story also
an OP to you that we promised you
please seek DNA of male staffers at
facility where vegetative patient gave
birth please Phoenix Police are
conducting DNA evidence from all male
employees of Hacienda health care where
a patient in a vegetative state gave
birth to a child December 29th
please serve the long term care facility
with a search warrant Tuesday the AP
reported quote we will continue to
cooperate with Phoenix Police and all of
their investigative agencies to uncover
the facts and it's deeply disturbing but
absolutely
but unprecedented situation the care
facility had considered conducting its
own DNA tests I do not I'm good I'm all
set but it's
tourney's advised that genetic testing
of its employees would violate federal
law the company said didn't know that
quote the family is obviously outraged
traumatized and shocked by the abuse and
neglect of their daughter at Hacienda
Healthcare the family would like me the
lawyer representing the family to convey
that the baby boy has been born into a
loving family and will be well cared for
blessing you got a look at it and it
ended terribly disgusting disturbing
moment like this you got a look at the
positives there's a new baby and nobody
knows who his dad is but he has a family
and this family was just like gaping
hole in their lives from their daughter
being in a vegetative state they have
some happiness and I guess that's good
also a question an answer to one of the
questions asked yesterday which was one
of the former caregivers told abc15
quote I can't believe someone would
bathe her daily for nine months never
know she wasn't having her period she
wasn't growing in her midsection so she
should have been getting her period and
either they were failing to bathe her or
they were failing to take care care and
he wishes well so while it's apparently
illegal to collect data they should just
be like this you know if you're a dude
and you didn't do it give us your
samples it's illegal for the facility
itself to ask employees for their DNA
but now this police have a search
warrant and they're and they're taking
DNA it's the most horrible thing I've
ever heard like I can't get over it and
this is weirdly going back to the are
Kelly thing sorry but it's like it's
really annoying sometimes how like there
are a many a situation where like the
police can't do anything like they're
standing outside the house they know the
girls are inside but they can't legally
go in right they can't leave you know
what I mean like that's annoying
yes but in this situation like they are
working on behalf of someone
whereas if no one right there's no like
victim yeah yeah there has to be someone
who's prosecuting right I understand and
someone they're prosecuting on behalf of
well the story is just Pittsville and i
feel like even when you find out it's
like the type of thing you find out and
like it doesn't even matter like it's
still a terrible story it doesn't even
matter I wonder like it's a boy or girl
the baby boy yeah cute pivoting I don't
know yeah I don't ever it's just like
and a lot of toasters who are like
nurses and work in these types of
facilities they say like long term care
it's like a really it's like a sad place
to be because these people don't need
like daily care because they just they
just like lay there but so and that so
many [ __ ] up things happen in these
types of facilities specifically because
like there isn't people like
they don't Eve is everyday so there's no
aiming like why isn't my daughter gonna
bet they don't know because they come
probably maybe once a week at most
yeah it's really sad that's really sad
we will continue I'll take that you on
this story because it's shocking it's
Chuck and it needs to end like it needs
all of the potentially it can get so
that like everybody knows about it the
next time someone thinks about mounting
on a vegetated girl they'll know them
twice right and they'll know that the
police are coming for your DNA whether
or not you did it so also maybe
discourage your co-worker if you know
that he's knocking on a vegetative girl
not [ __ ] cool not cool next story a
little exciting bachelor news Kaitlyn
Bristowe and jacent arctic the Vampire
Diaries
might be the next match made in bachelor
nation heaven okay the toaster is called
it first yeah I know this year I knew
this years ago um but I wonder if the
bachelors gonna try and like make it
like um like make them go on paradise or
some [ __ ] pretend like they didn't know
each other like that's so classic them
you know I don't think hey let me do
that and I also don't think that he
would dude I think he would he would but
I think he would also be okay saying no
he's not like the thirstiest of them all
he's he's just regular amounts of thirst
yeah but not like new heights even
though she doesn't need to go on better
days no but good for him she's finding
happiness and who apparently Shawn has
moved on yeah really a bunch of toasters
said that they have seen him around with
a girl and it was written in Us Weekly
and she looks sort of addressed it like
on her podcast I think she said it was
just like she was like sad that's sad
has a lead ever gone on paradise no
Chris soules was supposed to write but
then he murdered someone yes so that
threw a wrench in his plans it did but
he would have been great on paradise um
so I think it really is like a slice of
humble pie for Ali to go on paradise
because you're also gonna see people
that you date it's a septa thank you
tonight and now here we all are you had
the power you were in the power position
and I already know Kaitlyn's season was
kind of a long time ago I don't know if
any of her guys are still circulating on
the Paradise circuit uh cuz I've been
Higgins you know
yep but it's like Jared and it's been
Zhi he was just there was that two years
ago now yeah and Jared is out in a while
makes you think yeah so she wouldn't see
anyone she knows but still I don't think
she would do it yeah nor should she
they seem to be like Cuba now that on in
Graham and Sean are broken up weirdly
enough it's like The Bachelor is
including they used to like hate her and
Sean like never include them on anything
when they were like the biggest success
story and they loved to promote their
success story so now that they're broken
up they're bringing her in which is even
weirder like I think that they would
want her when she was in a relationship
that the bachelor facilitated but I'm
happy for her me too
she did a good job with the hosting
thing agreed and I could see these two
together cuz he me too
he seems like a good like solid guy
right like with a back-up plan like a
job right and I was gonna say I don't
know if he has a job but he seems like
he would have one but if someone told me
he has a job I wouldn't be surprised
yeah
so I'm here for it and I'm here for her
happiness and whoever that's worth yeah
um next story I chose for one sister and
now that another sister has arrived I
think you guys will find this
interesting this actor refuses to kiss
actresses on screen boom and then I will
tell you who it is he played a soldier
who once killed a German with a perfect
renamed lob to the head but don't ask
him to gasp kiss gorgeous actresses for
the cameras Band of Brothers and
Desperate Housewives actor Neal
McDonough who plays crazy Dave oh my god
he is not famous right says his
religious belief oh by the way for those
who don't know him he is the guy who was
married to Edie tried to kill MJ and
Susan big lies lies like white hair oh
it's always looking like the scary
serial killer scariest person in every
film says his religious beliefs an
undying devotion to his ex model wife Oh
him I thought it was like his I'm not an
emotion to his ex-wife I was like [ __ ]
pathetic to his ex model wife Ruth a
Robertson keep him from getting up close
and personal with co-stars are on screen
even if it costs him jobs and the hefty
paychecks that go with them well clearly
it has because he doesn't work - since
to us what else was stopped quote I
won't kiss any other woman because these
lips are meant for one woman the
Catholic actor recently told closer
weekly okay I'm sorry I think this is
weird like I know it's like supposed to
be honorable but it's just like a part
of the job and when I was younger or
like any opportunity I've ever had to
like talk to a celebrity I'm like you
can't yeah but but like I got over it
because I'm a grown [ __ ] woman weirder
about it is that someone wrote it up
because it's clear that like this
decision of his has impacted his career
because I only know him as Dave from
Desperate Housewives that's literally
the only thing I've ever seen him in but
also he is like put into a box by
looking like a serial killer
no but do you know any roles there are
for serial case he admitted that his no
lip service stands has lost him work in
the past including an estimated 1
million dollar gig on the set of ABC TV
scoundrels in 2010 and I'm sorry I've
more to say by the way money is wife I
can letting him turn down 1 million
dollars so it's big it's not gonna maybe
Han that have sex I'm sorry I'm not here
for that I completely disagree with you
because like don't be an actor and you
can't act no but like Hollywood is deep
reme check hands it's not depraved
it's not ready it's not Supremes because
on set they have to fake it it's to pray
because people like our Kelly can keep
girls into their house definitely but
like the fact that like Judd Apatow will
direct a movie with Leslie Mann and
she's kissing another person in front of
him like that is a like when you take a
step back just like as a normal person
that's like that's weird
for sure but it's a part of the job like
yes but you know what like and if you
can't handle it jump be and like if you
don't want to kiss someone who's not
your wife
don't be an actor don't still try and be
an actor and take out an integral part
of acting okay I'm gonna say like if I
were an actor yes I would definitely
like you know plunge into all facets of
acting no you have to that's called be
an actor but I can respect him it's a
cool move yeah I just I'm thinking maybe
he should update his LinkedIn because
it's looking like he's gonna need a real
job soon no he's doing okay he's like
one of those guys down $1,000,000 he was
in paul blart mall cop too like come on
Ange ed angels in the outfield wow he
has a really good um he's in a lot of
films what do you kiss a man uh uh he
didn't say I just wanna I want to know
if he's being dramatic like cuz it's not
cheating on his wife because he doesn't
like men so but he also wouldn't like
the woman that he's kissing like it's
not exactly it's acting this is so
unbelievably stupid I can't really turn
down 1 million dollars
I mean I'm gonna say I respect it I know
different strokes for different folks
maybe he just loves he loves the craft
you know so like why should have to give
up his dreams instead he's making it
work for him
really I don't think he's making it work
because he doesn't really work except he
does okay like he's still living off
those Hulu Desperate Housewives checks I
mean go and get it go and get it working
on it go and get it I'm working on it
Dave you got my vote okay now this is
our sixth story because it's gonna
launch us in to our our Kelly recap but
our Kelly is under criminal
investigation in Georgia following
docu-series literally as of yesterday
our Kelly's reportedly to subject of a
criminal investigation in Georgia thanks
in part to surviving our Kelly the
Fulton County District Attorney is
looking into the singer and a mansion he
previously owned in Johns Creek Georgia
reports the blast
Kelly's former home is featured in the
six-part lifetime jockey series
highlighting his alleged sexual
misconduct with young girls last July
Kelly penned a 90-minute song in
response to the numerous allegations
against him I admit according to the
website investigators have already
interviewed alleged victim Asante McGee
who was featured in surviving our Kelly
walking through the property describing
did you watch other women held against
their will what it was when she goes to
the house because he gets evicted cuz
he's not any money so the house is empty
now
she goes back that girl Asante oh no I
didn't either so sad in 2018 McGee told
BuzzFeed quote our Kelly's the sweetest
person you will ever want to meet but
Robert is the devil the police have also
contacted Joycelyn savage and ordered
her to come in for questioning
while savage has claimed she was with
Kelly of her own free will her family
and friends believe he has brainwashed
her the blast reports that one of the
charges authorities are looking into is
false imprisonment the TMZ video of her
with someone in the background like this
that was crazy
that was crazy and the TMZ video of her
with Dominique and before the Motte like
before they focus on that I knew it was
her oh my god such a pig okay so if you
haven't seen it surviving are Kelly feel
free to watch it but I'm gonna give you
such a detailed thing it's gonna feel
like you were there even it's not really
a spoilers thing because a lot of this
has been like in the news so it's not
suspenseful in that sense but it's like
you don't even realize like how deep in
dark it's a six-part series that just
documents his rise to fame and then his
rise into becoming and literally the
monster that he is but what's so
interesting and when they were
describing him in the beginning like his
rise to fame how he was molested as a
kid I'm like don't make me feel bad for
him like I was
but that ended up being really important
because you see it's like he even before
he was actually famous but he got like a
record deal he was like a star on the
rise like he was spending all this time
at his local high school when he like
had graduated already he was hell-bent
on being a predator famous or not famous
right and I'm glad that they put that in
before everything and not after because
sometimes it's like they if you say all
these horrible things that they did and
then you try and explain it by saying he
was molested as a child it feels like
you're like justified but the fact that
they did before we got to know who our
Kelly is I like as a person
and they had this brought both of his
brothers but the one other brother who
was also molested who turned out to be a
very decent human being it's just proof
that like yes your canoe like it's sad
he was molested and and he it's a cycle
of abuse but like it didn't happen to
his brother you know and his brother was
a good guy and he turned on his [ __ ]
brother right that was really what was
pissing me off at the end and then the
other brother who was in prison whose
only person advocating on his behalf
like that the irony was he's so scared
he says hurry but he's in prison right
like so it's like the only person out
here who's offering another the other
side of it is someone who's literally in
prison for god knows what but it ain't
good no it ain't good so and I loved his
other brother I thought he was like such
a good guy and I like felt so bad for
him especially when like the brother
said in court like it was my brother in
the end of thing like that was oh my god
so more players when the fighters lame
it's hard to allude like that yeah I
mean his brother the celebrities who
were in it I found so interesting and I
didn't understand my Wendy Williams was
in it until she did the interview with
Kerry and then she had that phone call
with our Kelly have gone today yeah no
okay I have to tell you because it's
important when then like years literally
20 years after allegations have started
coming out there became this movement of
mute our Kelly black girls matter and it
was like the cats out of the bag
and he called Wendy Williams our Kelly
two hours she said it was completely
confidential and she said he told her
everything they admitted to everything
she didn't say admit she just said he
told me everything and then when she
said she won't say it's confidential why
is it confidential she's not doctor she
said like she would keep it confidential
for him why does she owe him jack squat
I know I thought she's not a doctor I
thought that was weird that's weird
well but I mean
I mean I trust her but silly she hasn't
a women [ __ ] the documentary was done so
well because Sparkle who I love she was
so pretty she was in it throughout the
whole thing and they didn't understand
why until you realize her niece not only
was had sex with that girl Lisa Anne was
the girl in the video being keyed on and
then was also the girl that that radio
host met like she's still there she that
was she was very arc of the whole thing
that fourteen-year-old girl look that is
so upsetting she's still there and her
parents wouldn't let her testify and
like he still plays guitar with him like
the parents are still like a naughty boy
so disgusting my foot is like so itchy
it's so disgusting and like it was
really like when he got off it was so
upsetting because two things and someone
made a valid point they were like if
this was our Kelly and all of the
victims were white he probably would
have gotten convicted for sure but also
you can't really convict someone when
the victim isn't saying it was me so
it's like borderline impossible to get a
conviction when the girls like no sign
of me I didn't do it right so it's like
it's like who's suing him right out no
right horrible like we had him and after
that he really thought he could become
anything he wanted and what really stuck
with me it's like at first with the Ilia
stuff and his songs age is just a number
so sexual on stage like putting girls
heads in his crotch grabbing his penis
like he doesn't care but then once he
got away with it he tried to cover it up
and heat his music change like he became
like this gospel like the world's
greatest the best song I believe I could
fly but they didn't even mention where I
noticed singing at the Olympics like he
became this figure in America and his
music like they said they said it's
literally like wedding music like in
most black weddings like all of his
songs like they walked down the aisle
and now their memories are tainted with
these are Kelly songs like you don't
want to remove it that's why they didn't
wanna take him off the radio that's like
they had a hard time separating his
music which is like hava nagila for us
from the monster who created it you know
yes but figure it out figure take your
figure it the [ __ ] out although I could
have done better
oh so you if you got married ten years
ago and that I knew dance to our Kelly
songs at your wedding before you knew
that he was a monster like your memory
that memories not tainted like that's
your [ __ ] money it was a great day
don't let our
Helly ruin it totally just stop
listening to his [ __ ] in the future and
the last episode which you've yet to see
is like the justice just in the forms of
like Spotify taking his music down
Atlanta radio agreeing to stop playing
his music it's all good but it is so
late noting that it's so late and so
many lies have been ruined and they
didn't touch on it but I need to know
the Lady Gaga bat all because it's
really weird
yeah especially just the the song itself
I didn't realize even in 2013 when it
went to the VMAs like he was pretty much
canceled yeah and what's so crazy to me
I always like associated like are Kelly
like oh P weird ostracize for me all I
but just for even someone who's very
involved in pop culture from art me
being like not being an R&B fan but
knowing who are Kelly is and him being a
little bit before my time all I knew was
like really good at what he did a couple
years ago isn't as successful anymore
has a weird fetish with peeing I didn't
know the whole underage child predator
thing you know right because it's not
spoken about and it's so weird how he's
like really protected and did you get to
the masked person yet yes they're in it
but they haven't they're not gonna say
who it is okay but and I think my
television man see where'd you see yet
no they do and like even and I was
really surprised that his assistant
didn't mask himself to because he
admitted to doing like a bunch of really
[ __ ] up [ __ ] like going to malls with
him and getting 14 year old girls and
giving him his phone number their phone
number
well I appreciate them just coming from
like no but it's like anything I'm
thinking if you think of and that's what
the wife said she was like yes he's
terrible but you know many people had to
arrange cars contact the girls get them
but get their flights booked like the
amount of people involved in this whole
scheme that weren't actually having sex
with the young girls but making sure
that they got to where they needed to be
to have sex that's what's even scarier
is the people who were complicit yes I
don't think that's scarier then then
then our Kelly himself it's it's no but
like if you think about the the wide net
of people who had to who knew about it
right but it's also people who depend on
him like running right I think what's
the most [ __ ] up is one that like
record executive said okay he did this
but how much is he bringing in right
that's someone who can live without our
Kelly like yeah you'll lose a little
money but like big [ __ ] [ __ ] up 11 of
and making wish justice for the girls
justice for the girls justice for the
girls
whereas Azrael wears Azrael wears Azrael
wears Azrael we start telling where's
Georgie like we're starting we're
struggling the COPE thing was really
like what got to me but what's crazy
so that BuzzFeed article that they
reference in the movie that is really of
modern times of what he's doing in the
cult I when that came out I read it and
I was just like this I already thought
like negative things about him that was
just like this is so like weird like how
was he like still doing shows and blah
blah blah and still no one really cares
like me and enough cuts of footage of
people outside this concert so like I
don't care what he does in his personal
life I like his music what what oh what
also I had an interesting thought
because when when the hashtag started
coming out and then the article came out
it's like as much as I really [ __ ]
hate the world that we live in like
everyone is so sensitive and like you'd
be like and a BuzzFeed is the worst like
it's almost like it's it's just it's a
stunning dichotomy of like where we were
ten years ago and where we are now it's
like only now in this type of culture
which I kind of hate could an article
like that be written and people are now
taking it seriously whereas like people
knew about this stuff ten or fifteen
years ago they didn't care juninho so
it's like the world we live in now is a
2018-2019 is like annoying but like it's
also great because like things like this
come to life the Internet has helped
things like this company except when
that article came out in 2017 like still
no one really cared it's like the
weirdest thing and you know what I think
really like change I think for a while
it's like people didn't know how to
cancer like how to listicle e cancel
people and now we're over cancelling
people yeah but we got too excited the
Harvey Weinstein bill cosby's Kevin
Spacey like and I think really started
with Bill Cosby and Harvey Weinstein
like them being taken down like in such
a way now like has set the template for
how other monsters can be taken down
whereas for so long people and the no
one knew the steps like first it's you
know firing then it's really and then
it's absolutely shot is the advertisers
it's it's everything
and obviously y'all have taken it a
little too far right in some places but
it also has helped in situations like
this well what's so crazy also was like
the whole world is being taken by storm
by this is documentary like everyone's
talking about our Kelly he's been
trending on Twitter literally for four
weeks and the girls still locked up in
his house like have no idea
yeah but I think though it's still
pretty new ish like now they don't want
you baby they can no but like we just
watched it yesterday like look like they
literally they're one namin why not
psychiatrist said like they might you
know have a day where there's like they
go look at Google and see what people
are saying like they'll they just need a
moment like I know it was so crazy was
his wife who was so beautiful and so
brave so brave when she just like
googled like how do I know if I'm in an
abusive relationship it's like you know
what those like those like PSAs you see
in like those websites and like they're
important yeah it's like you don't like
for me it's like if I see an abusive
relationship
I know it's abusive but if you're in one
you might not know so you literally have
to Google and she was like lonely 15 out
of the 17 things on the list of abusers
like he does to me every day I really
think and everyone was really great I
think about like the sex and the
terrible things but they were like I
can't even speak on like the really bad
thing so it's like I was hearing like
the not terrible things and they were
[ __ ] terrible right you were healing
like the palatable rice so insane so
insane I really hope that like this that
they are able to pull him up on charges
I know it's just like the world has
turned and that that's important but
where's the police
the police are there they're ready to go
but they need something
when Audrey Alam was like I've been to
prison I don't mind going back I was
with her I miss I haven't seen that part
I'm sorry it's okay it's like because
it's not even about the suspense of like
what's gonna happen next it's like just
listening no but when don't when when
she went to the man back when she when
the mom went Michelle we think her name
was went back to the hotel they were
like your daughter called the police I
was like are you [ __ ] kidding girl
I'm like Stockholm Syndrome are you for
real and then she called you she was
like I knew it wasn't you and I'm like
oh yes it wasn't hominid Oh and I felt
bad that I believed it was and then when
they're walking out arm and arm like I
just I literally couldn't stop crying
like it was such an amazing and a killer
they got on camera I know but then but
they did in a way they said the mom was
like she doesn't want to be on camera
and they turn the cameras off obviously
shouldn't forgot she was still wearing
microphone and I'm glad that we had the
audio but like lifetime was extremely
respectful extremely respectful and I
really think as much as like the
internet is helping move things along
BuzzFeed article even though that really
didn't like have much effect much change
documentaries are doing so three
identical strangers like
repetition yell we're gonna get our ting
movements they're really starting
movements and opening people's eyes and
they're also like I just think it's the
best format for serving up some justice
the daddy thing like freak freak and
it's like if he just like has this whole
run of show plans right like it's like
so systematic it's it's and they all
have the exact same story right and what
was so like really sad about it's like
of all the survivors that they that they
interviewed there was one maybe two of
girls who who couldn't who wouldn't let
themselves be controlled or abuse a like
they saw one weird thing and they were
out like you haven't met her yet but
faith Rogers like she saw something she
was like this is [ __ ] weird and left
and there was one girl in the beginning
but for the most part she really knew
how to find girls who were vulnerable
Mike came from you know bad homes with
them with like not great family
situations and like really like latched
onto them and separated them from like
the one or two people in their life so
really cared about them and they made
them think like they don't love you I
love you like [ __ ] psycho that god
complex it was giving me um it was
reminding me of the whole scandal with
the church and it was like the words you
just air drop me something yeah I know
it steps up but she's an analyst and I
want did you read that thing no I almost
did decline it Margo air-dropped of
something I know I was just gonna talk
about it but I wanted you to see
themself we'll talk about it next week
I'll finish it tonight um it was
reminding me of the church and the
priests how would they use God and like
intimidate people who come from broken
homes kimmy schmitt sure that's what I
was akin the whole time um that mom was
like so brave because when I was she was
so patient and I guess there's like a
way I mean I don't know but like if you
if and I'm sure she had been in contact
with many psychologists who were to say
look if you do come in contact with your
daughter I don't yell at her like she
was so calm and she was in she was on
the phone and she was like okay whatever
you want I'll come at six come and when
she was like I'm sure was so hard
Fuhrman she was at the hotel room for
them and Dominique was like there's
someone here you actually even she left
like she was very calm and persistent
and never was like screaming come home
like she did such a good job I could
look if I was that was me I couldn't get
in the [ __ ] car right now
yeah are you [ __ ] kidding me again
like that would be me but she was so
calm and like temp I'll am sure she
she tried that before yeah and in two
years that she didn't see her daughter
she tried every every method I just
couldn't believe they got that on camera
I know and then I thought we were gonna
go get all them you know bring back her
like that's literally but I thought that
we were gonna go in Azrael and we almost
did I have to watch anyways
really upsetting everyone should should
see it because it's also just like so
disgusting to see like a predator you
know the taxes act he uses how it really
could be any what you think oh you look
at this you're like oh how could they
fall for that like it's easier than you
think
totally totally especially talking with
someone you look up to him the thing
like all these girls were innocent upper
one fans and they really didn't think
that they really thought that like the
public was trying to take him down with
that video and they were outside of his
trial like saying we believe you we love
you and like he used those types of
girls the girls who adored him and loved
him like to infiltrate their minds sick
guy own said oh so the most interesting
part is at the end they do updates on
all the girls and literally all of them
went into some sort of like public
service of like helping victims of
domestic abuse and they all like started
their own foundations like wrote their
both own books like it started hotlines
like it was really sweet that's really
see I'm excited to get there yeah crazy
but hope I just want to say one thing
about samarco that she was a great aunt
as well Oh totally I love sparkles Bay's
and loves her and like she didn't talk
to her family for ten years because the
parents of the girl and her other
brother the guitar player like testified
that it wasn't hurt could you believe
that no I couldn't no I couldn't okay so
now for some dear toasters for some
issues had our way less complex yeah we
do dear toasters it is hard by segments
we're doing to the speakers we're just
like right on top of that rose
you can email dear toasters at gmail.com
it is our anonymous advice segment we'll
talk about everything from you know
Bridal feuds to family drama but we
really like the interesting things we
have an update for you guys today also
but before we do that this is a dear
toasters it's a little short one it's
called alright like us it's called I
can't see the search bar where I can't
see the subject line okay so I've been
seeing the sky for about a month now and
we've we usually sleep at my house every
night but we ended up crashing at his
house last weekend after a night out
when I got home later that day I noticed
in the shower I had these little bites
all over my body some of my arm my
stomach and my ass I didn't want to jump
to any conclusions because
Department is very normal clean for a
guy so I didn't I thought maybe it was a
rash or something I don't know however I
slept there last night and the same
thing more bites now I know for sure
that this amazing guy been seeing his
bedbugs
what the [ __ ] do I do how do I even
bring that up I stuck with these
situations I feel like I can never look
at him again and I'm so uncomfortable
help that is so disgusting
no that's vile by the way dick finals
podcast is called the bio files oh good
for you I start on the podcast i
yesterday do you think that's a
deal-breaker no because if his apartment
is clean like bedbugs isn't from dirty
bedbugs can happen to anyone right it's
like life people have lice actually have
clean hair
yeah can't let him know discover it
don't give to be an actress's you got a
deal like hey babe let me change the
sheets and if you lift up the sheets
when you have bad bugs you see the bugs
there right there she be like babe these
are bedbugs like discover it with him
make him think it was his idea that's a
gift to treat men they're so dumped but
like I don't think that you have to act
on this one because like you just say I
got bug bites like I think you might
have beg bugs like let me call the
exterminator and just handle it like I'm
like so paranoid about people thinking
I'm dirty or like don't smell but guys
don't have those hangups
they don't care clearly I know how do
you like it bye bye see every night and
not notice like right maybe something
Thanks maybe she's allergic to his two
children staying at her place all the
time so maybe like he got bedbugs while
they've been dating and hasn't really
realized Oh totally cuz he's not
spending a lot of time in his own
apartment right I don't know you guys
like just oh they're like oh I
understand why she's perplexed because
like I personally like look I have you
ever been told that like you smell or
like your breath I mean I've been told
that my breath smells about you [ __ ]
but like yeah or yeah I guess it's like
not but not by the weather but like a
colleague or someone no yeah like that's
my worst nightmare yeah like having
having to Toby be told by HR like you're
you're you smell oh my god I know what I
mean yeah that's why I'm grateful for
Stanford I'm so grateful percent bird
membered is monthly subscription they
send you like test size tubes of like
fancy ass perfumes and it's not nearly
the same price and their travel size and
you get what is it like 120 sprays put
like that little bottle yeah it lasts
you a month if you're someone HR should
give those every day
a teacher should give those
and also they look like TSA should give
those out because people on planes smell
too and they're great for travel so we
both have them we both are subscribe to
him I like perfumes in general just
because like you never know and if you
don't want your hair a little spritz in
the hair can do wonders for a gal and I
like summer because I can try a
different sense which I usually I'm not
gonna like pick a cent out of a magazine
and like put my wrist but I can like
live with one for a month and see if
it's gonna be my new signature smell so
Sanford has over 450 designer brands
that you could choose from every month
Prada Gucci Kate Spade nest
I love nest I even know they made
perfume 120 sprays so you smell amazing
you choose a perfume and they'll send
you a 30 day supply we have an exclusive
offer for you you'll get 50% off your
first month today so it's seven dollars
and fifty cents for your first perfume
that's scent bird calm scen t-bird calm
/ toast use our code toast for 50% of
the first month that's scent scen t-bird
calm / toast sign-on smell amazing
use code toast I mean I use Co test and
I have a monthly subscription anyways
and I bring them when we travel because
we never have time to share our I mean
to shower and also on this new leg of
the tour me and Margaret starting it's
many times we don't even have a hotel
room so like I'm flying to Cincinnati
tonight and it's on off a tour I'm going
straight to the venue and from the venue
we're taking a car to Columbus so it's
like there's no time to shower and like
that's really where I got a spritz my
hair was tempered for the meet great cuz
it's not nice to meet people with that
kind of smell that's really true I just
keep one in my person every time I'm
like about to go into a meeting I'm just
like so glad glad that I have it uh what
kind of car so what the machine
we just started booking on that stuff so
I think we're doing for any Drive over
two and a half hours we're doing like a
fancy Sprinter like tour bus style and
for anything that's between like one in
two hours just like a like a car well
tour bus is Pitt now from our Kelly oh
my god totally with Aaliyah with
everyone with everyone everyone Oh
Aaliyah that was really sad but then she
she did it she died in a plane crash and
I wonder if I was like related to him
because I called I guess yeah she died
in 2001 um that stuff happened like in
the 90s with him like and I wonder where
they still fret like
but even after they got it Shirley
disappeared from the documentary after
that right but like did their
relationship just totally end abruptly
if you still produce her music by the
way he's still signed to RCA Records
that was the craziest thing and he
hasn't produced a hit in literally ten
years like that's the sort of thing
that's just an easy break evarin all
right here's the next one
this story is long and messy so bear
with me I had a best friend let's call
her Jan I've known Jen my entire life
literally there isn't one memory memory
without her in it as a matter of fact I
have had the same group of friends my
entire life one of them passed away when
we were in high school and that really
brought us all a lot closer as we've
grown up together we have done a lot
together traveled partied been a family
of anncr yada yada fast-forward 10 years
and one of the friends in the group had
a gender-reveal party so annoying an
extra I brought my boyfriend who really
didn't want to go do you blame him we've
been dating for 11 months I love him and
it took me a really long time to find
someone that I feel is my soul mate at
the gender-reveal there's a lot of food
liquor and good vibes I was finally able
to catch up with Jan and I told her that
my boyfriend really don't want to be at
the party and we had a few fights about
random things on our way to the party I
didn't know that Jan was wasted off of
pink and blue jello shots and a few
glasses of Prosecco I left the party
with my boyfriend maybe a half hour
before everyone else during that half
hour Jan started telling the friends
having the baby and her entire family
that my boyfriend didn't want to be
there that he almost jumped out of the
car on the way to the party anything
negative that I had said she pretty much
told everyone at the party including the
new parents which is like so sad she
also decided to ask a guest at the party
named Abby if she has fake boobs I sent
a screenshot of someone who I thought
was a B to Jan last week before asking
gent did Abby get fake boobs Jan showed
Abby the text which said which one sing
Abby in real life I knew was the girl I
took a screenshot of whatever I [ __ ]
okay she's getting confusing and this is
unnecessary Jan went so far as to show
the entire text message to a be throwing
me and my other friends under the bus I
did was even apology until a week after
I confronted Jan my response to her
apology was that she needed to get help
with her drinking I know Jan is on
antidepressants and mixing that with
alcohol it's since led her to blacking
out on multiple occasions this being one
I also know a lot of Jan's dirty secrets
and have sworn to take them to the grave
and I've lived up to my word I thought I
was just venting to a friend in a time
of need since then Abby blocked me on
social media my best friend is so my
boyfriend is so embarrassed and doesn't
want to see Jan or the girl wear the
gender-reveal party I've always been the
first to apologize but in this case I'm
not reaching out at all the
gender-reveal party
and over Thanksgiving break Jen didn't
say Merry Christmas Happy New Year
nothing since the initial apology if she
ever does reach out to I even respond is
it worth the Pitt huh okay because on
the one hand you know I'm all about
cutting people out of your life they
take and but this is like a lifelong it
doesn't matter people grow apart just
like Jeff Bezos and his wife married
since 1993 people grow apart it's so
funny I literally have the same like
state of mind and Ben is a total
opposite like I'm like someone did this
you know I got to come down with them
he's like but they're your best friend
I'm like it really doesn't matter I'm
not interested anymore right but like
having that sort of history I would that
just gives them a couple more chances in
my book but she's using every chance and
just totally destroying so typically I
would just say listen you have your
other friends you guys aren't there
anymore that's okay life goes on you
know people change let that let her
spiral out but like if perhaps benefit
of the doubt here like perhaps the
drinking on the antidepressants like
maybe you know she's being someone who
she isn't and this is the time that she
needs a friend more than ever
Brett you gotta see both sides like it's
not like she's sober and being an
[ __ ] like she's drunk at a party Plus
like her new meds and she's like she's
not well and this is the time to be a
friend so I don't know Jam so I can't
tell you which situation it is you do
Jen doesn't live the type of gal who
would take the time type of criticism
rather well no but like maybe she needs
help and like it's as a cry for help
maybe and mate and that's when you need
to be a friend yeah you know when you
can't back out without having at least
tried once try to help say I'm worried
about you if she doesn't respond well
then you back off and she'll eventually
come back to her senses and she'll be
like grateful for that you would at
least tried to help like if you if you
never try like are you a good friend I
don't think so I don't think so so I
think you should definitely sit her down
and be like I'm upset by all the things
that you did like really so [ __ ] rude
like sure Jan but I'm also worried about
you and like how can I help what can I
get one if she's an [ __ ] sayonara but
if she's like breaks down and is a sad
scene lend a helping hand okay so our
final dear toasters is actually an
update so let's recap it's a long dear
toasters the short version is is this
girl works in a law firm and there's two
partners one of them is like a little
bit of a freak lick is it kind of creepy
he's had some sexual harassment claims
against him and
and this other girl in her office saw
this creepy guy who they're calling Bob
like loading supplies into the basement
like 10 cases of water all different
brands like buckets covering it up with
blankets and like going down there to
check on it like every now and then it
was a really creepy you know it's it's
giving me he's like a amateur hour Kylie
perhaps right maybe he's turning occult
so they either chucking fun they were
checking the basement every few days to
see if anything else changed they
searched for 10 minutes they found his
stash tucked away behind a stack of
boxes it was covered with a blanket we
pulled the blanket off and took a look
it was the cases of water had doubled so
whatever it was just really weird they
never like got to a conclusion and and
the toasters were really taken by storm
and they reported it and um there was
nothing to be concerned about it she's
just weird oh yeah they consulted their
friend who was a pop they were like he's
out doing anything illegal just like
keep an eye on it and let me know right
so we were all in a pickle so she here's
the update we snuck down to the basement
again today to check on things there's
more [ __ ] water there in our 20 cases
and all of it is covered by the large
blanket I posted pictures anonymously to
the t-i a showing the scene so if you
guys don't know the TI a is one of our
morning toasters sub-communities it's
called the TI a the toasters
Intelligence Agency and they solve cases
like this doesn't one of the premier
intelligence agencies I would say and in
the world it's very difficult to
convince you don't even try and they
crack cases they find people they find
phone numbers they're really insane so
she posted pictures anonymously also I
noticed some of the things removed he
moved the boxes of buckets and placed
them about a foot or so away from the
water stacks his air mattress was on the
floor in the bag still but underneath
the chair about three feet up from the
water all the items were still hidden
from plain view they were just separated
none of the items had been used yet so
we believe he did this so it wouldn't
seem so out of some hold upon it and
stack together the combination of items
all hidden under the blanket that makes
it so concerning so we separated it I
guess he thought he was being more
clogged by like moving things apart
there was more context to add Bob's
brother who we called Joe was the owner
of the firm Joe told Bob last week that
Bob had to reimburse the firm for about
125 thousand dollars for the sexual
harassment settlements the firm paid out
on those claims over the summer there in
a major fight right now could the
basement activity have something to do
with this I don't know is he going to
bounce to Mexico to flee to avoid
reimbursing the firm he
fluent in Spanish but the items in the
basement aren't needed to go to Mexico I
mean there's water at any gas station
along the highway it doesn't make any
sense
the TA I had several comments and I'm
reading one of them in response to one
of them we can't go to HR over the
basements - because our HR guy never
keeps his mouth shut
he needs a new job he's a kiss-ass type
who runs to the boss with a boss with
every piece of info when he says it's
confidential
a snitch basically Marco do you work at
this offer we are on our own it's just a
scooby-doo kids watching this creep so
we wait we have a plan we are checking
the basement twice a week next time I'm
gonna get a picture of the tubes of
sealant SCAL ela and T what is that I
think we looked it up now so I can try
to determine what it can be used for I
think it was a glue or something se a
LAN T a and sealant is this substance
used to block the passage of fluids
through the surface or joints of
openings and materials but a Hoover Dam
for sure but it's used for teeth yeah
like I don't think it's used for walls
oh no here it's how to apply silicone
sealant I guess it could be any it's
immaterial people also search for coding
primers cement mortar and concrete resin
we are debating about asking the office
manager to request a key swipe report
from the building owner to see how often
and when Bob uses the basement she's the
only one with the authority to request
the report the risk of this is real
she's a real airhead it might spill the
tea on accident she's legitimately
stupid we are trying to get her hands on
a motion-activated camera to install
down there then we'll see what the [ __ ]
is happening ring this is literally
consuming my thoughts the majority of
each day keep any ideas coming please
I'm listening to and reading every
comment thank you please oh she said
please give me anonymous um
crazy crazy okay also that was an old
update because maybe there's new please
home girl reach back out email us if you
have any more information but it just
sounds like the equipment is keep keeps
on stacking up like he's getting ready
for some sort of trap like natural
disaster right I have two suggestions
perhaps first of all maybe tell the boss
his brother because it seems like
they're at odds anyway and like maybe
this is something you know there's more
going on between them and this would
like solve the case like it's like the
enemy of my enemy is my
we each are working toward something
it's like a house of cards when those
sad reporters are working on a story
about Frank and so are the people like
that work for Frank trying to take him
down and if only they just met they
could have taken them down together also
I just want to say that this girl like
don't get yourself and put yourself in
danger because this is really creepy and
I've been today like you're not a
policeman so like I don't want you to
like just get so invested like
installing cameras and like end up
getting yourself in trouble and like him
finding out or something because it's
obviously unstable my second thing would
be what if you guys I'll go down there
one day and just take everything out
right and just like bring it put it back
in the kitchen but there's power in
numbers you know she can't do it
ourselves no but she it seems like she
has a good little crew I think we just
heard the paralegal uh well maybe like
they go into one night and they just
start like clearing it out
that was so crazy so crazy but imagine
like he's doing it for a good cause in a
weird way right like it's for like a
local shelter right that needs sealant
me right no it's all very odd well
thanks for the update feel free to keep
us updated that was an update like that
didn't really type in the new sense it's
just made me now even more inquisitive
right and now with having seen surviving
r.kelly like I can only assume the worst
because people are dispersed some things
that people are suggesting it could be
he's preparing to move into the basement
and sell his house to pay back the money
he's preparing to move into the basement
so he can sell his house and pay back
125 grand that he owes the firm for the
sexual harassment claim quite a few nice
little brothers then can he just go
upstairs like if he's sleeping there he
could go up in the night and get it
water the hell does he need sealant for
maybe maybe there's rats and stuff yeah
yeah yeah anything else I don't know
very scary what a pit inducing episode
it's hold it oh my god hi so many pizzas
episode started with good and broken
ended with sealant that's the morning
toast for you I was well-rounded morning
show in the mornings we're the morning
toasts people live Monday through Friday
10:30 a.m. Eastern Time on YouTube and
we're also available as podcasts
available anywhere podcasts can be found
I'm Claudia joy your loyal morning show
host tickets to my show the girl with no
job dirty jeans store is available on
girl - no job com
I will see you soon it's cold Cincinnati
tomorrow Columbus Detroit this weekend
there's 50 tickets left get one I'm
Jackie O'Shea Jackie O problems you can
see me live nephew weekend out at Jackie
O problems hub thank you oh wow
I feel like
signed a land deal I'm really excited
I'll need words of encouragement all
weekend obviously it's gonna be a
weekend of premium content because Theo
produces nothing but that and yeah I'm
really excited I'll be back tomorrow
with joey camasta in a wig hopefully and
we'll be shooting the [ __ ] so if you
have questions for him will be posting
later ask away bye guys have a great day
you